[Applause]
Let's go ahead and try to block it from anti-
threat Dangerous
small power group First, there are too many holes for 20 years of preparation Is it
necessary to think about this and that for one statue to crush 1000 ants?
I'm starting to feel sorry for
you. You didn't realize that you
were already being watched by the Japanese government, or the identity of the man in front of you. Were you an assassin sent by the government?
I caused an internal collapse before, and the
recommendation is
over. I wonder if I was lying to President Nae Suzuki.
Toutetsunamja I'm old when I'm wrapped up I'm running away
I have
[music]
I'm the same as I Iku
I lost two chiefs and there's no such
thing as internal collapse The main force I recommend is Corporal As long as I and I
are invincible The second one is invincible I
hesitated It
's just you here  Oh, that's
right,
I went to my adoptive father.